bonsoir jacky j'ai confiance en vous
monsieur
premièrement voulait jacky que vous me
prêtez l'oreille monsieur jacques pas
nous écouter jacques lit parfaitement
chanter je suis je ne sais rien de vous
voir les magiciens voir les magiciens
qui lui arrive bien rester barman jacky
ça ne changera jamais
charles quel est pour vous le premier
lieu associés aux vacances berck plage
ces housses à berck plage c'est ta cote
est à côté de moi merlimont plage mais
c'est tout en haut de ces sur normandie
alors moi j'avais les jambes arquées 1
et à l'époque quand on avait des
déficiences dans les eaux on envoyait
les enfants à berck plage pour le
donneur pour le pour le bonheur et ça
m'a remis les gens de droite la tête
points mais les lambris vous ai des
souvenirs de bande de copains de grosses
bêtises avec les copains à berck non à
merlimont non plus n'ont porté le manger
tue toujours été un enfant un petit peu
sérieux comme on a eu un passé assez
assez difficile
alors on est en été les enfants sérieux
qu on nous disait toujours fait
attention pour se faire remarquer on a
été bien reçue dans ce pays tenez vous
bien et c'est en étant on se connaît
bien on se tenant bien manger pour leur
chose
vous avez des souvenirs d'amours de
vacances petite fille sur la plage comme
ça à berck où un gradé - bram
j'avais commencé très tard votre premier
baiser ça a quel âge en 12 ans à 12 ans
12 ans web et aider des chansons de
cette époque qui vous ont marqués en
voleurs y en a plein c'est quoi par
exemple les gars de la marine marine
elle s'est pas légale la marine joue les
pères de la fri pour tourner dans les
cols bleus je dirais que laureen et là
bas quand j'ai pression certificat
d'études en ma vie du film demandé de
chanter une chanson je chante et
marie-aude la whey et on met des gants
vous a plu jeudi à genève orient cgt les
moyens légaux comme moyen l'argent
témoin la marseillaise
ouais on pensait que je connaissais pas
la marseillaise j'ai réussi à en sortir
quatre couplets qu'on va pas mal oui
parce qu'ils avaient peu de français qui
ne le savaient et l'adolescent c'était
quoi vos vacances aux vacances de
rétention ou pas parce qu'on n'avait pas
les moyens
je crois que les premières vacances qui
sont tes premières vacances on les a eus
à 13 ans j'ai encore une photo de mes
parents et d'un groupe
d'arméniens dans l'eau jusqu'à la
ceinture et que le poing levé parce que
c'était le front populaire et que
c'étaient les premières vacances payées
vous avez déjà des 500 dans la tête à
cette époque oui j'avais déjà écrit une
chanson avec ma soeur elle avait fait la
musique j'avais fait les paroles j'avais
la première chanson j'ai écrites quand
j'avais 7 8 ans c'est une histoire d'une
voiture amphibie qui parle qui allait
sur l'eau et sur la terre je me souviens
plus très bien mais ma fille ma soeur
s'en souvient alors des fois elle même
mal rappelle aujourd'hui vos vacances
c'est quoi c'est un drop et saint tropez
uniquement uniquement j'ai fait le tour
du monde plusieurs fois j'ai vu les plus
beaux coins du monde
bon je me suis arrêté un capoolco chéri
en thaïlande un peu partout que la
floride la californie le plus beaux
coins du monde c'est d'abord sur la
méditerranée bon c'est pas si la corse
bien sûr mais moi je me sens plus à
l'aise ici ça me permet de voyager
d'aller encore de revenir
et là vous avez acheté une maison à
saint tropez mais vous trouvez pas que
la région est un peu galvaudé quand même
donc la région est très très construit
très bas tique un peu frelaté l'était
sans trembler comme avare de boire le
verre est très bien préservés
d'autre part saint tropez c'est
l'auberge espagnole vous voulez vous
éclatez vous éclater voulait rester au
calme au restockage voulait dans un coin
particulier vous pouvez y aller vous
faites ce que vous voulez à saint tropez
les gens qui viennent me dire on va pas
à s'introduire s'il ya trop de monde ça
n'est pas vrai il ya du monde sur le
port vient de visiter puis repart si
vous voulez vivre normalement vous
pouvez vivre en famille tout à fait
normalement mais vous qu'est ce qu'est
la première chose que vous faites quand
vous arrivez en vacances premier jour
d'abord je n'arrête pas de travailler
pendant huit jours ouais je sais pas il
ya des choses à faire dans une maison
qu'on n'a pas abandonné pendant un an
donc je fais toujours plein de choses et
il faut tout revoir tout refaire et mes
vacances commencent lorsque tout est
terminé
alors au bout de huit jours qu'est ce
que vous faites après en vacances je
fais pas grand chose le matin j'ai créé
un petit peu et puis je descends sur le
sur le port pense qu'il ya pas beaucoup
de monde le matin là je prends mon
journal je vais au bistrot je rencontre
les journalistes habituellement ils sont
tous là on peut faire une photo jean ont
d'ailleurs prévu ayant réservé beaucoup
en vacances des journalistes il me fiche
la paix ouais on se connaît depuis très
longtemps et le côté paparazzi ça
n'existe sur tout ça n'a pas tellement
exister en france mais c'est vrai alors
ses horaires comme ça très très sérieux
de déjeuner à 2h de vous coucher tout
vous coucher vers quelle heure le soir
les jeunes amis viennent
ouais je me couche vers 10h30 ah ouais
avec un bouquin mais là je bouquine
jusqu'à minuit à bord ou alors j'ai des
choses à apprendre à mémoriser je le
fais le soir dans mon livre c'est là
qu'on apprend le mieux vous sentez pas
dans les boîtes
non j'ai eu mon temps ouais qu'est ce
que vous faites quand vous faites rien
alors dans la journée ah non moi si elle
n'arrive pas d'orienter à bonds dont
j'ai toujours quelque chose
par exemple je sais pas en moi ya
toujours un truc à réparer à bruz tard
voir quelqu'un rencontré quelque chose à
écrire un coup de téléphone à donner non
non j'ai toujours quelque chose à faire
faites du sport en vacances n'ont pas de
sport non on joue aux boules
non les jeunes au casino non non je suis
pas joueur disait pas jouer annonça
alors pour un oriental pendu tout l'un
fait des siestes n'ont jamais n'ont même
pas des siestes crapuleuses ce que l'été
c'est la grande spécialité quand on vous
oriente
quel est votre meilleur accessoire de
repos l'été le sable le livre le hamac
n'y en a pas mais pas il en île où vous
avez pas vous allonger sur la plage on
je m'interroge produite je ne me mets
pas au soleil ouais je vis au soleil
parce que finalement ce qu'il faut c'est
profiter du soleil mais se mettre au
soleil qu'il y en a même qui ont un truc
en moins sur le coup comme ça et fois du
soleil que la figure et puis à la fin de
leur vie son étage dans tous les ans je
ne pense qu'à un coup fait passer à
votre temps regardez j'ai pas
d'opération il est parfait je sais pas
mais bien si c'est très en forme et
votre femme
elle va bien merci voici maintenant sur
lèze à vous
[Musique]
bonsoir sur les avoue très heureux de
voir sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle
merci ça va bonne année 2004 oui ou non
nous avez fait quoi pour les fêtes
rien rien moi j'ai fait c'est pas
important pour moi oui non
pendant des années les fêtes c'était une
matinée de plus oui quand c'était pas
deux à bien des bus pour frôler pour les
gens qui de matinée en plus sévères du
travail ça veut dire une représentation
pas une grasse matinée
attendez roddick - ça parce que je suis
beau dit le président vous dites une
matinée en plus ça représentait une
matinée une matinée de music-hall vous
voulez dire un spectacle en bus oui
peut-être les gens n'avaient pas compris
chez eux
charles a peut-être ça va être ça tout
le temps charles sans déconner moi je
alors aussi six ans
charles est ce qu'elle est ce que vous
avez pris les bonnes résolutions pour
l'année 2004 je vais travailler avec
d'accord sur une meilleure des
résolutions allant vous sortez un nouvel
album chez capitol imai qui s'appelle je
voyais aller avant d'en parler on va
faire un résumé des épisodes précédents
didier envoyer les gens
randy foye plus gros pour n'importe qui
m'ont lancé dalet
signons mes photos est d'unir à terre
et mieux
tout a changé en cinq ans
tu te laisses aller
laisse aller
tu es belle à regarder très bas tombant
sur tes chaussures et ton vieux peignoir
mal fermées et des bigoudis qu'elle a
lue il faut savoir encore
[Musique]
meilleures recettes
bien
bravo les magiciens
il
comme bien
pas
tu as vu
pour la mère et grizzly qu'on est un peu
dans le petit bois de trousse chemise on
fait des bêtises souviens toi nous deux
on était parti pour trousse chemise
[Musique]
et
tu es
je lai
je vais
rodez l'espoir riches bourgeois
de folie
[Musique]
il faut moins
juste à
livrée
ça jamais
ils sont venus ils sont tous là dès
qu'ils ont entendu ce cri elle va mourir
là
moi
fournit 100
nicolas
formi formi formi formidable
aucune you see me s'immiscer mais c'est
minable
arc bleus que le bleu de ses yeux je ne
vois rien de mieux
même le bleu des yeux
on ne peut s'imaginer
m leblond des blés que c'est triste rire
autant les amoureux ma route
que c'est triste denis
comme on le sait
hier encore j'avais 20 ans
ressel temps les jouets de la vie comme
on joue deux
aurais je vivais la nuit sans compter
sur mes jours qui fait vous parle d'un
temps que les moins
à connaître
mon art en ce temps là
[Musique]
crochet ses lilas jusque sous notre
planète
si l'humble garni qui nous servent et
dennis ne payait pas de mine de sel
c'est que lui moi qui criait
et toi qui pose nue chaque rue
[Musique]
on se
oh
au soleil désormais
[Musique]
oubliée
et
[Musique]
les bruits familiers de la boîte
or si gai
qui tue aux curieux
[Musique]
j'habite le seul avec maman dans un très
vieil appartement
bruce arasa
me tenir compagnie
une tortue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
je
[Musique]
le sait
souvent
c
et la cuy
mes amours
[Musique]
samedi
les jeux
à
la mémoire
[Musique]
16 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais je voyage donc c'est le titre
c'est le type de la chanson c'est aussi
le titre du dernier album de soul
aznavour donc douze chansons sur votre
âge et j'étais encore ya une ambiance un
peu walt disney dans cette chanson je me
trompe je ne sais pas c'est une bonne
question la question pas ouais ouais
moyens là aussi c'est une problème si tu
peux éviter de les poser quand je parle
c'est tout d'accord mais qui parle tout
le temps même tenté ça c'est vrai je
suis venu parce qu ils ont fait moi je
veux bien que j'avais ma gueule tant que
je sais que vous savez que je suis là
bien alors je voyage
[Musique]
alors je voyage c'est le titre donc de
la chanson avec katia c'est aussi le
titre du nouvel album de charles
aznavour donc douze chansons sur vos
sujets favoris la jeunesse la société
l'amour la nostalgie
une chanson qui s'appelle la critique
car vous dites on a beau dire au fond
que l'on s'en contre fout elle vous
détruit le moral et vous en fout un coup
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense que j'en pense c'est que vous
qui avez jamais répondu c'est à dire
vous allez jamais abordé le problème de
la critique vous avez jamais répondu ni
par téléphone et par courrier vous avez
toujours ignoré les critiques et dieu
sait si vous en avez eu je trouve ça
formidable que un jour comme ça vous en
vous en parliez en disant plus la vérité
c'est à dire non on s'en fout mais en
fait ça nous fait du mal quoi puis-je
est amusant de le faire aujourd'hui
pensent que vous êtes une vache sacrée
aujourd'hui à dire dumas n'ont même plus
personne peut dire du mal de vos charges
c'est sûr lorsqu'un peuple gérer mais
j'avais envie de faire non c'est bien
parce que c'est pas amer en plus vous
dites oui c'est vrai la critique on les
écoute que pamela merde tu devrais je
sais bien il ya une fois quand même où
s'était un peu chose c'est qu'on vous
ait fait l'olympia en 55
il y avait un journaliste qui avait
écrit pourquoi ne pas chanter avec une
jambe de bois
c'est vraiment méchant donc là vous avez
exigé un droit de réponse et la seule
fois d'ailleurs sur radio luxembourg
vous aviez droit à trois minutes sinon
vous êtes resté neuf minutes vous en
trouviez plus la wii a d'autant plus je
venais d'avoir un accident alors là j'en
sais moi j'aurais pu la voir on nous
faisait beaucoup enduré quand même au
début avec votre physique votre voix vos
chansons ah j'avais tout contre moi
c'est vrai la voix les chansons disais
que c'était pas c'était pas populaire
c'est devenu pape et des régions 17
commercial est vrai oui c'est vrai j'ai
eu droit à tout un jour au crazy horse
et vous entendez quelqu'un qui dit j'ai
jamais entendu rien de possible
oui il était devant moi j'avais envie de
donner un coup de pied dans la figure
mais ce n'est pas dans mes habitudes il
ya un journal qui avait écrit maintenant
laisse chanter les handicapés mais
c'étaient des trucs maintenant on lit
plus ça dans les critiques n'ont
maintenant tellement chanté justin et
petrucciani a fait la carrière concède
empêchons évolué
pour le mettre sur huit charles sinon on
va se faire chier alors sur les avons le
22 mai 2004 vous fêterez vos 80 ans sur
la scène du palais des congrès ce sera
la réussite ou croyable pour réussir et
même avoir 80 jean 81 ans est en fait à
peine 60 très à part l'audition est
alors donc le 22 mai 2004 donc j'aurai
80 ans sur 5 ce sera la dernière de vos
représentations qui commence le 16 avril
je le dis on je dis à tout le monde
parce qu'attention lui sur scène c'est
trente chansons incessamment ah oui 30 à
la mode rappelle pas de rappel et 30
chanson she vol des rappels je m'arrête
à 25 mais c'est pas la peine et la perte
de temps alors il est très secret un
vous acharnez ça vous êtes très très
très pudique vous êtes absolument
inintéressant
parce que je suis un intéressant dans
les journaux en question
je lis suis jamais on a fait un petit
sondage sur vous change un homme
67% des français pensent que vous avez
une tortue 3 canaries une chatte par
exemple c'est crevettes congelées gpar
est criante voilà 13 % des français
pensent que vous êtes chauffeur de taxi
à tobrouk
comme quoi vous devriez quand même
beaucoup plus loin des mouches
demeureront à 6 way we grandes répliques
4% des français trouvent que vous leur
faites penser à quelqu'un sans qu'ils
puissent retrouver le nom et alors là
91% des français pensent que vous portez
les talonnettes
non j'ai failli alors pas besoin
non non de regarder la propagande
entendre ces voix intérieure qui permet
aux sharks
denoncourt café
voilà merci je cirer les pompes hallyday
gémissant souliers affirmé pied quand
même puisque les cheveux donc je tiens à
dire à vos amis téléspectateurs qui vous
connaissent mal c'est pas une perruque à
vous avez fait d'un nouveau jeu les
mêmes noms exacts de l'accord oui c'est
ça elle vient de l'armée de la save
achement bien marcher chez les bruins
mais la terre est bonne si vous avez les
cheveux un petit peu long en ce moment
c'est parce que vous allez faire un rôle
assez pas du tout pour faire le jeu
c'est pas pour ça cool parce que vers le
père goriot votre nouveau né a été
offert par par piaf vous raconter ça
dans votre autobiographie le ton des
avants paru chez flammarion et avec
gréco c'est vrai que les télés les
premiers mois je me souviens vous faire
refaire le nez on en parlait à la maison
c'est un événement aujourd'hui tout le
monde se faire refaire le nez
non galabru l'a pas fait car si vous
étiez les premiers avec la colombie si
c'était assez scandaleux à l'époque
quand même en bon bah moi on l'apprend
su parce que j'étais inconnu
ouais donc on a fait les cheveux on a
fait le nez est alors le plus tu es
faisons la visite
avant ce que tu sais pas ce que tu sais
pas c'est que quand il était petit chat
réseaux avaient les jambes arquées oui
déficience pénis est marqué les gens
s'imaginent jean louis xiii voilà louis
xiii à dire ça vous alliez en vacances
c'est tragique de berck à berck le nom
derrière avec berck
ben voilà non mais c'est une jolie plage
berck plage magnifique magnifique vous
avez survécu à tous à vous avez survécu
à la critique on l'a vu j'ai survécu à
la guerre parce que c'est vrai pendant
la guerre quand je vais partir on va
dire que je suis au mieux que ardisson
non mais c'est vrai quand vous étiez
petit on sérieusement vous étiez souvent
par l'occupation j'ai souvent mené à la
kommandantur on vous prenez pour m oui
oui vous étiez emmené à la kommandantur
aider avec le nez que j'avais je pensais
pas pour un français pour son bel effet
refaire en 45 c'est trop tard oui alors
vous avez survécu d'abord à cause de ça
ensuite vos parents était sympathisant
communiste il gagne avec manu chiant de
btp maïs rouge donné des coups de main
voilà ça c'était il venait chez vous
manouche ans il venait nous après les
échecs
oui venez chez nous et puis ça sa femme
a été cachée chez nous lance 8c les amis
de longtemps voire avant donc survécu à
la kommandantur survécu à la
fréquentation dessus increvable mais
c'est vrai alors vous quitté l'école à
l'âge de 10 ans il ya 15 ans on fait du
marché noir pour nourrir votre famille
parce que votre père était engagé dans
beaucoup de gens de venir à ce jugement
et là vous vendez du chocolat des
charcuteries et des débats pour femmes
oui à qui les vendaient aux boutons via
le monde
ils ont manqué à vouloir dire ça alors
j'allais aux portes de paris avec ma
petite sacoche comme ça et puis je
proposais mais baa aux allemands qui
voulaient absolument en acheter dans les
h et je me souviens exactement du pij
demandé tout c'est toujours 20 marques
un ordre d'occupation mais je partais
vite parce que dès qu'on pensait la main
dedans ça filait alors un jour il ya un
riche arménien
qui décide de faire une bourse comme ça
pour aider des petits arméniens les
enfants démunis
vous vous retrouvez dans une école pour
apprendre la tsf enfin ça vous ennuie
énormément évidemment centrale
voilà de tsf rue de la lune voilà et
féru de la lune vous emmerdez vous
sécher les cours pour aller au cinéma
d'après midi au music hall le sens où
alors j'allais aussi voir gens qui s'ils
avaient des cours de comédie gentil
c'est dans l'assassin habite au 21
c'est ce que j'avais à dire je t'adore
l'on sait exactement je suis moi même je
fais des films
et alors en 1941 vous rencontrer pierre
roche si vous faites un duo qui
s'appelle roche et aznavour départ et
vous êtes embauché par tous voilà
c'était dans des boîtes de nuit
on a fait beaucoup de remplacements
aussi et en 45 votre première chanson
j'ai vu est interprété par georges ulmer
et leurs montants la refuser cette
chanson ça c'est incroyable et que ça
meurt à la fin c'est intéressant ça
quand même vous vous êtes un jeune
auteur compositeur de chansons êtes en
face d'yves montand qui est quand même
déjà une star il vous dit moi je suis
d'accord pour chanter la chanson si à la
fin il meurt ou dit non non mais j'ai
même eu des des chanteurs très connus
qui voulaient y consigner les gens sont
jeunes ont gémi pan jamais donné la
moitié d'une une oeuvre à quelqu'un qui
n'a pas travaillé dessus
comme je n'ai jamais parce que je
changeais une ligne pour vous une phrase
à dans une chanson de leur camarade je
n'ai jamais dit je signe avec pas joli
vous êtes bien ouais la classe car là
c'est la classe et et montant a refusé à
ça c'est encore pire que tout je me
voyais déjà
oui en dix ans il ya jamais une chanson
sur le métier qu'à marcher c'est fou oui
mais là c'est excusable parce que la
plupart des gens pensaient la même chose
alors en 1946 francis blanche vous
présente
edith piaf c'était dans une émission de
francis blanche à l on a connu bien mais
c'est pas lui qui nous a présenté c'est
elle qui vous a fait comme ça comme
salma fait comme dans la chanson avec
l'appareil
et alors elle vous ouvre un petit peu
les portes de l'amérique vous allez
alors vous faites un coup boli vous
décidez d'aller chanter au carnegie hall
à new york paul fait apam kanté
personnes vous louer un avion avec 150
journalistes vous payez vous louez le
carnegie hall e3400 place vous chantez
vous fait un tabac évidemment après tout
le monde il a réussi au carnegie hall
donc le monde entier vous appelle qui
risque rien n'a rien c'est assez fort et
oui
sans parler on devait en parler anglais
en lisant le texte un i la tête pas de
talonnettes mais il a des couilles le
sas et vous avez peur de la mort ça ça
dépend des jours où j'ai demandé nuit
exactement aujourd'hui ça va aujourd'hui
ça va très vite
vous croyez vous aurez droit à des
funérailles nationales non non non ou
alors en arménie a peut-être mais j
aurais pas là bas j'ai un cas vraiment
france on en mairie avec ledroit un mot
pour la warwick c'est bien là tout le
temps blessé
à bas les attendait à cabo à montfort
l'amaury aussi que vous connaissez le
lieu non c'est un cloître du 3ème siècle
ah oui pas n'importe quoi et puis en
face gg en marche à un peu plus loin
j'ai ces sigles g marshall 1 il ya du
monde chez nous à ces six candidats oui
et je suis mieux que j'ai un effet
construire ce qu'il fallait
d'ailleurs j'ai la folie de la
construction alors bien sympa voisinage
impasse que le sculpteur ya des
embrouilles après c'est le bordel je n'y
couperai page sur les amours on m'a
offert une interview funérailles
nationales
[Musique]
c'était un petit peu difficile pour vous
puisque vous êtes mort donc vivement
recommandé alors je suis mort de
vieillesse
ouais vous l'avez trouvé comment le
discours de chirac à l'enterrement
or un peu tremblotante et quand l'équipe
de la star academy a chanté emmenez moi
ça vous a ému
oui je pense surtout que c'était la
nouvelle équipe les anciens n'étaient
pas venus j'avais des béquilles vous
aimeriez qu'on dise pas debout
maintenant vous êtes mort charles
aznavour pas qu'on dit du bien
ouais ouais mais du bien bien pour
n'importe quoi
combes de grandissement vous rendez vous
avec vos ventes de disques sont repartis
c'est énorme depuis que vous êtes mort
vous avez revu mes arrières
petits-enfants et s enfonça sk des
oeuvres posthumes des trucs que vous
avez jamais publiées et en vivant et qui
vont ressortir maintenant comme les
beatles
ah oui oui j'ai laissé ma voix sur des
bandes électroniques nouvelle et ils
ajouteront leur qu'est ce qu'ils
voudront ajouter de sucre ça génial
est ce que vous savez qu'on va
rebaptiser rue aznavour la rue sarah
that
ah oui oui c'est delanoë le quai
toujours maire de paris qui était sarah
that je sais pas un violoniste espagnol
à un grand violoniste espagne je me suis
renseigné quand même si le derrière tout
simplement fikiel nom est dire si ses
envies pour le reste non je me suis
renseigné
c'était quoi votre dernier mot avant de
mourir charles aznavour je reviendrai à
bravo
holmes
alors sérieusement avoue quelques mails
les gens savaient évidemment que vous
seriez là ce soir ils ont envoyé des
mails sur le site france2 qui s'inscrit
en bas de l'écran
vincent torres de toulouse dites-moi
chose à vous vous avez fait fogiel
drucker en aparté la star ac
il se vend pas votre album ou quoi non
on l'a fait pour que ça se vende ouais
mais c'est ça d'accord nicole guibon des
de boulogne billancourt
est ce que vous pensez qu'avec la
canicule l'été dernier vous avez perdu
une grande partie de votre clientèle
non je le prends part je l'avais déjà
renouvelé
j'aime quand vous faites ça bien
stéphane gonzalez de strasbourg vous
allez reçu en 1974 le prix de l'artiste
pop le mieux habillé
pourquoi ne pas vous être changé depuis
là vous avez un peu stoppé
je dirais simplement que une fois qu'on
l'a dit plus d'importance à la fois un
mail d'hervé bodineau de bron savez vous
qu'il existe un remake d'un taxi pour
tobrouk qui s'appelle un taxi pour que
j'te bruce willis
[Musique]
je voyais
le monde
non il est publié chez flammarion
[Musique]
ah oui bon sillon très bons clients
changent d'un jour car elles vont
l'abandonner c'est comme ça vous revenez
quand vous voulez même si vous n'avez
pas de disque ou de livres à vendre
pourrait revenir du vin courage et pas
toujours quelque chose mais quand vous
voulez voilà l'enjeu montrer votre carte
bancaire
le si est amusante aussi de la même
couleur mais lui autre chose car des
alcooliques anonymes
ah bah oui confrérie des cons mieux vaut
être super con que rien du tout et ça
c'est magique que vous êtes beaucoup non
on n'est pas nombreux nommé yahia marcel
jullian il ya jean reno et gad mais on
n'est pas nombreux et ne voit pas on n'a
pas une chanson les pendules santé n'ont
qu'a écrit charles aznavour l'arménien
c'est que ces visites
voilà et là avec la carte de bons
clients tout le monde en parle vous êtes
reçus partout dans le monde entier
ah c'est vous monsieur aznavour
[Musique]